we got this breaking news from
timcast.com biden's vaccine mandate for
business is blocked by the supreme court
the court wrote the occupational safety
and health administration was not
permitted to broadly regulate public
health i agree i think they're correct
they wrote requiring the vaccination of
84 million americans selected simply
because they work for employers with
more than 100 employees certainly falls
in the latter category
where they said although congress has
indisputedly given osha the power to
regulate occupational dangers it has not
given the agency the power to regulate
public health more broadly the dissent i
find actually kind of humorous
in the dissent the liberal justices
wrote because it really was split six to
three
when we are wise we know not to displace
the judgments of experts acting within
the sphere of congress marked out and
under presidential control to deal with
emergency conditions today we are not
wise in the face of a still raging
pandemic the court tells the agency
charged with protecting worker safety
that it may not do so in all of the
workplaces needed as disease and death
continue to mount this court tells the
agency that it cannot respond in the
most effective way possible
well there it is and the daily why uh
the daily wires doing a victory lap
because they were leading the charge on
this they were i think one of the i
think they may have been the original
lawsuit i'm not sure yeah but here we go
that's it joe biden's out no vaccine
amanda right i think brandon wants to be
a dictator so this is definitely a step
back for him but he's also urging
businesses and states to still implement
this on their own i'm surprised he
wasn't begging the supreme court just to
censor all the arguments here against
his vaccine mandate this is a major blow
against his agenda against the narrative
and thank goodness we don't live in a
country like canada or austria or
australia where people are literally
being robbed of their wealth for not
complying with the whims and medical
advice and then still you know by and
large it's still crazy i bet you
probably agree with this too matt that
we have to be in a place where you know
some mystical figures and robes decided
that we could decide what medicine to
take for ourselves that's that's where
we're at right now that's crazy it was
it was insane and i was freaking out
today because um earlier in the day
everyone expected this to come out and
then they re released some other nothing
burger decision about something that i
don't even remember what it was and i'm
like oh [ __ ] are they gonna punch punt
for a week
and and happily they did the right thing
but the absurdity and even even
listening to the more conservative
justices arguing that it would be okay
for a state
or or someone further down the food
chain a different government official to
then impose on you
this this this mandate that you have to
take this vaccine
um i'm i'm of the old school where
individual freedom and and freedom of
conscience is is actually a real thing
and i thought that's what america was
but yeah we we dodged a bullet today and
that that was a cool thing i i ascribed
to
a theory that thomas massey introduced
me the day that joe biden
announced this and you remember they
dragged their heels on the rule and
massey's theory was they know it's
unconstitutional they know they're that
they're going to get shot down but in
the meantime they're going to bully as
many businesses as possible into
complying with this and i feel like
biden is proving that theory today you
can't unvex yeah and so what happens is
a ton of businesses when they heard joe
biden issue his press conference which
was not even executive order they just
went okay everybody you got to do it you
heard joe biden and then people
were basically mandated to do it now
they went and got vaccinated they come
back to work and the company goes hey
everybody it's off we actually don't
have the we don't have to do this too
late yeah so i think that was the plan
from the get-go and i feel like um and
maybe we'll get into this in a different
context but i feel like if you were
forced to get vaccinated maybe secretly
you want to kind of force everyone else
to do it too because you're pissed like
you got you got sold a bill of goods
yeah i certainly think that's true i
mean you you take a look at uh we talked
about this last night
uh
vaccine mandates don't work and when i
say they don't work what i mean is in
new york new york city i think they had
the first vaccine mandate they have
skyrocketing coveted cases right so
whatever whatever this the point of this
policy is it's certainly not stopping or
abating the spread of covet but yet
still you hear these these democrats and
these these these you know city
politicians say it is working why it's
forcing people to get vaccinated it's
not stopping kovid it's just forcing
they call that working yeah so it sounds
to me like they're like i don't care why
you do it just do it i don't care what
the results will be just do it the
culture the culture of compliance right
yeah that sounds like extortion to me
just just a little bit there but there
was also another ruling specif
specifically with health care workers at
facilities who are receiving medicare
and medicaid funds which was ruled
against them which means that people who
are working in these facilities will
have to take the vacs or lose their jobs
at a key time where already seattle and
los angeles hospitals there have
announced that if they have nurses and
doctors who have tested positive for
covid that they need to come back into
work that is absolutely insane seattle
and los angeles also implemented vaccine
passports for their employees in the
medical staff and and now we're having
covet positive patients
excuse me covet positive nurses and
doctors literally go back to work
dealing with other people inside of
hospitals all in the name of what safety
and security and health yeah sure well
think about medicare and medicaid so
medicare serves uh seniors over 65
who would be most vulnerable to covid
and most susceptible to ending up in the
hospital medicaid of course serves poor
people so the effect of this most
hospitals take these programs but some
don't but the effect of this
is to specifically understaff hospitals
that are serving seniors
and and people that are struggling to
make ends meet that's what they're doing
this is how government works they're
using government health care now and and
telling people are going to take away
their health care if they don't follow
the government's orders well the logic
was if we're paying for it we being the
federal government we get to tell you
what to do with your body exactly so
welcome to government-run medicine this
is how it works they own you and they
decide what you do have to do but they
also decide what you don't get to do
like joe biden has nationalized
monoclonal antibodies
yeah oh one of them
they're trying to shut that down i'm
hearing yeah so i was actually recently
told by a med
medical worker that
they no they were told monoclonal
antibodies no longer work and that
they're not to recommend them and that
to me is insane what yeah well it's just
me personally look i'll tell you we
always tell everybody we're not here to
give medical advice and that's like a
big topic because of so much of what's
going on the pandemic go talk to a
doctor and see what they say about it
because i'm being told that they're
starting to pull monoclonal anybody's
well i had a friend who was sick with
covid19 and you know they were they were
having a very serious case of it some of
the early preliminary data is
highlighting how some of the antibodies
don't work but there is one specific
antibody that does work with omnicron
but for delta a lot of them do work by a
broad basis this is just again some of
the preliminary early findings i'm not a
medical doctor not here giving you any
kind of medical advice but it has been
siphoned off and my friend who was
trying to get antibodies for herself and
her husband because they weren't doing
too well was told because of biden
because of the governor in new york you
can't get them and there was even an
article in the um the daily mail that
said whites need not apply for critical
uh covert care for antibody uh care
because of their skin color as of course
they're also passing laws in many places
like in new york where if you were born
a specific skin color you're denied
access to medicines compared to other
people because of their skin color
remember uh death panels hmm yes i mean
i i yeah what was that that was back in
like 2008 that was like fear-mongering
techniques of obamacare that there's
going to be government-run health care
and the government's going to decide who
lives and dies uh that was that right
that was the story wrong was that wrong
that's exactly how it works yeah and i i
know this very personally my wife uh
terry got got covered over christmas and
okay i'm i'm gonna get monoclonal
antibodies and it turns out that they
pulled two of three types of monoclonals
off the market the byte administration
did
because the assumption was they work on
delta but they don't work on omicron
and so they pulled all of these things
away from the hospital so in in our case
we couldn't get treatment for my wife
she's fine now but it she would have
done better with them
and then it turns out that you know we
thought it was all omicron but it's not
really all omicron there's a lot of
delta out there
and and it's sort of a lesson in how um
single top-down decision-making works in
government they just arbitrarily said
you know what it looks like omicron now
well it wasn't
and catastrophically someone at the
margin probably died because of this
government decision we don't know who
that is
but but someone could have gotten
treatment and and some bureaucrat in the
body administration said you know what
we're not going to let you yeah i think
i think there's no one here as a fan of
centralized command control you know uh
economic structures or governmental
structures right no you know in the
military so i i mean when it comes to
military yeah
when it comes to military i understand
the need for authoritarian top down
general that's that's that's a fair
point though i agree with that yeah
that's why we have
an executive structure you know because
when we got to move fast in emergencies
it does make sense but we're at this
point now where too much is being
absorbed by this executive authority
it can't be
you know total control of our medical
system in one place
the fda is also intercepting packages
with medicines that some people are
using to help treat this so when you
have the government outright intervening
in such egregious ways and you see the
result of it when more people being hurt
it really really should leave a lot of
people with the questions what are they
doing here other than making the
situation that much worse for everyone
else as you said the fda was
intercepting packages with specific
medications that have been a big topic
of debate uh obviously these are the
medications that joe rogan has talked
about before i don't even want to name
him because of the kind of hot button
i came across a video on twitter where
it's apparently there's been a bunch of
uh thefts of train packages in la i
don't know if you guys saw this on the
scanner they heard about it they went
down there and it's like just ripped
open packages of amazon packages boxes
covet tests fishing lures epipens crazy
is it piracy is it good is it this is
what crossed my mind as you were saying
that are people being privateering these
stuff back so what we were talking about
i wanted to uh
get back to the point about executive
authority and the need for you know
emergency response
my view of emergency response is there's
an agency that says okay we're going to
go to these local communities that are
affected by a pandemic and ask them what
they need and we can do that very very
quickly because we have the authority to
respond rapidly
but not to dictate what the communities
have to do not to go to local mayors and
say you're now mandated to do this so
when you look at here's what i love
about about mass mandates especially
we we work on the border with frederick
county and i think washington county and
maryland and so you can like walk 10
feet and there's a building with a mask
mandate and then walk 10 feet and
there's one without and it just
literally makes no sense and then the
crazier thing is the further the further
out you get from the center of the
county the less likely you are to even
experience the mask mandate which it
just does not work but then they want to
start punishing businesses and finding
them and it's just like look
being able to rapidly respond to a
crisis by showing up with resources you
can spend money you have people working
under you and you can say here's what
needs to be done makes sense
but if you go to a community you ask
them what they need you don't tell them
what to do you know yeah i mean that
that's the dream but the problem is
there's uh there's a fatal conceit um
when you give these guys that much power
um they have their own theory about how
to do it and and in the most disturbing
example of this we all know is andrew
cuomo overruling nursing home providers
murdering 15 000 murdering 15 000 people
um he probably thought he was doing the
right thing he probably thought he knew
better than them and the the problem
with uh governments using local
knowledge is is that arrogance they
don't they don't want to see the fact
that they don't know because that's
political danger for them i i disagree
um with andrew cuomo not thinking he was
doing the right thing though like i
understand your point i agree with that
but cuomo had the mercy medical vessel
and the javits center and he was like
i'm not giving trump a victory kill the
old people
he was warned cuomo was warned if you do
this you will kill old people
and he said instead of using the under
the the javits center which is only at a
third capacity or the mercy vessel which
isn't being used at all i'm going to
kill the old people and he did or the
central park hospital that was there
that had received no one i mean you
could even fashionably say that he was
on the phone with his brother at cnn
being like hey we need more of those
debts to boost up ratings as of course
there's cnn officials literally bragging
about how they were happy how more
people were dying because it was
gangbusters for ratings which is
absolutely absurd so again that's the
thesis it's sensationalistic to say that
but it's not out of the realm of
possibility with how they've been
behaving man we i this this is kind of
stuff that makes me want to do sketch
comedy because you can't do it on
youtube but you'll be able to do it on
rumble yeah where you just have chris
cuomo call up andrew and he'll be like
chris my show's not doing too well we
need more deaths what can you do for me
well little brother uh i got you i got
you we'll just kill a bunch of old
people ah i i you look uh it's it's it's
meant to make fun of them for as bad of
people as they are but
uh andrew cuomo knew what he was doing
oh people come out it was standard
protocol this is why there's such a big
kind of uh you know talk about
conspiracy of him being outed because if
he got hit with that if he got was if he
was responsible for that so would a lot
of other democratic governors in
michigan in new jersey who would have
been held responsible for it and that's
why there's conspiracy thought talk of
andrew being kind of taken out so there
there wasn't any kind of possibility of
him facing any justice for that specific
cause because it would implicate all
these other governors that were
democratic that were following orders
from the federal government that was
telling them to do this thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time